si ces 3% rejoignent nos projets mais si
vous avez la conviction de vouloir
défendre le camp des travailleurs
pas du tout mais pas du tout mais pas du
tout
fonctionnaires contre les syndicats du
nouveau rejoignez notre attention contre
le premier travailleur immigrés sur une
partie de la souverain écoutez moi j'ai
presque envie de vous dire tellement
j'ai l'affection appelez-moi Jean-Claude
je vais vous appeler Harley écout
ez 500000 voix tout changer madame lagui
d'ailleurs je vous ai amené un cadeau je
vous ai amené mon livre les 100 premiers
jours de Jean-Marie Le Pen à lycée
mais non madame laguier et vous verrez
que ce n'est pas ce que vous pensez vous
avez parlé
pas Arlette